le 1er février 2012 j'ai pris un avion
de toronto à pékin par ou pensez-vous
qu'il est passé par l'europe à l'est ou
par le pacifique à l'ouest
quand je suis monté dans l'avion je n'en
savais rien et c'est en regardant le
hublot que j'ai découvert la réponse
l'avion toronton pékin passe par le pôle
nord
et oui j'ai survolé le pôle nord mais ça
ça peut pas être très surprenant surtout
quand on regarde la trajectoire que l'on
a suivi sur une carte
et bien notre carte favorite celle que
l'on retrouve dans tous les livres
d'histoire et sur google maps
la carte dite de mercator est fausse
voilà à quoi ressemble le groenland et
l'afrique sur la carte mercator voyons
quels sous leur vraie taille relative
est ce que c'est ça non puisque c'est ça
non parce que c'est ça oui le groenland
est vraiment si petit ou plutôt
l'afrique est vraiment si j'ai honte
la superficie de toute l'europe
tiendrait non pas une fois non pas deux
fois mais trois fois dans celle de
l'afrique
ça peut paraître anecdotique mais ce
genre de carte a le mauvais goût de
flatter les égaux des pays du nord en
les agrandissant littéralement les
cartes du monde ne sont pas juste une
représentation de la réalité elles sont
devenues notre présentation de la
réalité
et ça à l'historien arnaud pieters
l'avait bien compris
peeters proposa donc une alternative à
la carte marque à tort qu'ils elles
respecter les tailles des pays
mais le grand public rejeta cette carte
dite de galles peeters sous prétexte
qu'elle était moche
qu'est ce qui fait que la gamme pieters
et ça marche prenons une autre carte
vous voyez ce que c'est oui c'est juste
la mercator mais avec le nord en bas
elle n'est donc absolument pas plus
fausse que la mercator
pourtant elle paraît étrange voire
désagréable si on n'aime pas cette carte
c'est probablement parce qu'on n'y est
pas habitué
se pourrait-il qu'il en soit ainsi mais
aussi pour la gale peeters se voit-il
que la raison pour laquelle on n'aime
pas galles peter c'est juste parce qu'on
n'a pas l'habitude de la voir sans doute
un peu mais pas uniquement
la gale peeters a le gros défaut de mal
représentés les formes des pays quand on
zoome sur une partie de la carte on voit
que les formes des pays sont très
différents de ceux que les satellites
voix
on dit que la gale peeters n'est pas
conforme
en particulier les angles de la gale
peeters dit faire des vrais angle sur
terre al'inverse n'a mercator a le bon
goût d'être conforme ce qui rend le zoom
de google maps si agréable cependant la
gamme peter ce n'est pas la seule carte
conforme sur son site web
jason davis liste un grand nombre de
cartes dont beaucoup sont conformes
ces cartes sont fascinantes après tout
chaque carte est une merveille
mathématiques
d'ailleurs au xviiie siècle la
cartographie tu es devenu la sphère de
matheux comme lambert lagrange et euler
mieux encore au 19e siècle gosses cauchy
et rimane ont su relier la cartographie
à l'étude des fonctions à variables
complexes ses fonctions joue notamment
un rôle crucial dans l'hypothèse de
riemann dont lg j'y parle dans une vidéo
récente du coup on peut se demander si
on ne peut pas faire mieux que la mer 14
il ya eu des tentatives assez originales
comme la carte de lambert celle de goût
2 ou celle de waterman
mais ces cartes conformes ne sont pas
des représentations entièrement juste
existerait-il une carte vraiment
parfaite bien non
goce prouva en 1827 l'un des plus beaux
théorème des mathématiques
le théorème a écrit diot
ce théorème dit que la géométrie d'une
surface peut-être déterminé à partir
uniquement de mesures l'intérieur de
cette surface par exemple en
additionnant les angles d'un triangle en
particulier sur terre la somme des
angles d'un triangle est supérieur à 180
degrés surtout si le triangle est grand
du coup dans toute carte de la terre il
doit y avoir des triangles dont la somme
des angles est supérieur à 180 degrés
évidemment si les angles sont justes
ceci est impossible à faire avec des
droites droite on a dit que les angles
sur la mercator était juste donc ce sont
les droites de la terre qui sur la
mercator ne sont pas droites et c'est
pour ça que l'avion toronto pékin avait
une trajectoire s'est arrondi sur la
carte
alors que l'avion semblait voler tout
droit al'inverse les droites de la
mercator ne sont pas toutes des droites
de la terre prenez par exemple un
parallèle très proche du pôle nord ce
parallèle fait en fait le tour du pôle
nord donc si on cherchait vraiment à
suivre cette trajectoire sur terre
devrait faire petit cercle
ce qui ne correspond pas du tout aller
droit
mais donc pourquoi la mercator est elle
si omniprésente pour répondre à cette
question il nous faut faire un petit peu
d'histoire
à l'époque de girard mercator au xvième
siècle l'europe partait à la conquête du
monde avec sa flotte de voiliers
or pour naviguer les marins utilisait la
boussole le compas et la mer 14
il alignait ainsi le nord de la boussole
avec le nord de la mer 14 puis reportée
l'angle de leurs déplacements par
rapport au nord de la carte
cette construction n'est valable qu'avec
la mercator carin mercator est la seule
carte conforme pour laquelle le nord est
toujours en haut
si on y réfléchit ça veut dire que les
voiliers de l'époque ne voyageait pas en
ligne droite pour aller de l'europe à
l'amérique du nord
il a les pleins ouest or on a dit que
suivre un tel parallèle n'est pas
voyager en ligne droite
en fait les navigateurs de l'époque
devait constamment dévier leurs
trajectoires vers la droite pour rester
le long et parallèle leur bateau ne
naviguait pas droit et ça ça dit quelque
chose qu'il va être super important a pu
prendre surtout quand on parlera de
relativité générale une ligne droite sur
terre ou ailleurs correspond à ce qu'on
n'obtient lorsqu'on cherche à garder une
direction de mouvements constante en
particulier j'entends souvent dire que
les lignes droites sont des trajectoires
qui minimisent ou maximise d'une
certaine distance c'est tout à fait vrai
mais je pense que ce n'est pas une
définition naturelle et intuitive des
lignes droites ligne droite sur terre ou
ailleurs c'est surtout ce que l'on
obtient lorsqu'on cherche à garder la
direction de mouvements constante
géométrie intrinsèque possiblement
courbe ça correspond à dire que l'on va
se déplacer dans une direction et que
notre direction de mouvement va être
transportée dans notre position future
cette idée correspond vraiment à garder
la direction de mouvement
constante mais la constance de la
direction de mouvement est dicté par
l'espace qui nous entoure
mathématiquement la manière dont une
direction de mouvements se transporte un
bout des spasmes à l'autre et ce que
l'on appelle le transport par allen
géométrie extrinsèque par exemple sur la
surface d'une sphère vue à l'intérieur
de l'espace de dimension 3 une direction
de mouvements un endroit donné nous
dicte notre position future mais elle se
projette aussi sur la surface pour nous
dicter la direction de mouvements futurs
autrement dit le transport parallèle en
géométrie extrinsèque nous est donnée
par la projection de la direction de
mouvements sur les boudent espaces
voisins sur terre à cause de la
géométrie de la surface de l'inter de
trajectoire initialement parallèles vont
finir par s'intéresser kt et au bout de
quelques dizaines de milliers de
kilomètres en fait il n'ya pas de droite
parallèle sur terre il n'y a que des
directions de mouvements qui sont
localement parallèle les droites de la
terre sont ce que l'on appelle parfois
des grands cercles et intersec toujours
à deux endroits où type au dos et
surtout si les droites ont l'air de
vouloir s' intersecté ce n'est
absolument pas parce qu'il ya une sorte
de force qui les attire si elles ont
l'air de vouloir s' intersecté c'est
uniquement dû à la géométrie de l'espace
dans lequel elle évolue
et ça c'est une idée qui va beaucoup
plaire un certain albert einstein
j'espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo
alors il y avait quelques petites
approximations voire des trucs sans
explication dans cette vidéo du coup
j'ai écrit un article de blog popov
clarifier certains points
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à la ligue et à la partager et à la
commenter
pour c'est aussi à vous abonner à la
chaîne pour ne pas manquer les futurs
vidéo et j'espère que je vous verrai la
prochaine fois et je te montrer des
cartes sanaa
rien à voir avec le monde d'aujourd'hui
allez marcel la bibliothèque nationale